et ces tensions au proche-orient
affronter qu un peu partout dans le
monde importante manifestation
pro-palestinienne chicago aux états unis
manifestations en france également à
l'issue de laquelle le président de
l'association france palestine
solidarité a été interpellé puis relâché
il sera notre invité dans quelques
instants pour un débat la préfecture qui
interdit officiellement ce soir le
nouveau rassemblement pro palestiniens
prévue samedi à paris à la demande de
gérald darmanin qui évoqué les
manifestations violentes de 2014 alors
le conflit peut-il dépassé les
frontières avec des répercussions en
france notamment c'est l'objet de notre
face à face ce soir et pour en débattre
nous sommes donc avec bertrand et beaune
président de l'association france
palestine solidarité bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés richard
abitbol président de la confédération
des juifs de france et des amis d'israël
bonsoir messieurs à tous les deux merci
d'avoir accepté ce face à face alors que
la situation effectivement est très
tendue et les débats explosifs les
manifestations pro-palestiniennes 1
prévue samedi officiellement interdite
c'est la préfecture qui il a dit à
quelques minutes à la demande du
ministre de l'intérieur avant de vous
faire réagir messieurs je voudrais vous
faire écouter donc ce message gérald
darmanin à paris j'ai demandé au préfet
de police d'interdire les manifestations
de samedi en lien avec les récentes
tensions au proche-orient de graves
troubles à l'ordre public furent
constatés en 2014
consigne a été donnée aux préfets d'être
particulièrement vigilants et ferme
alors vous qui appelait à cette
manifestation en bertrand enron votre
réaction ce soir après cet interdit
officiel nous appelons à manifester
surtout dans toute la france parce que
c'est vrai que c'est ce qui se passe en
palestine ce qui se passe ce qui s'est
passé à jérusalem ce qui se passe à gaza
qui très bien montré par votre reportage
est quelque chose qui crée une très
forte émotion en france et vouloir
interdire à cette émotion de s'exprimer
ou leur interdire la société civile de
demander à notre gouvernement
tu es plus clair d'être fort d'avoir une
expression fort pour
condamnée et ce que subissent les
palestiniens de la part d'israël d'avoir
une expression forte alors
qu'actuellement il est dans le camp des
expressions extrêmement floues c'est
quelque chose que c'est notre droit et
je veux dire que vouloir interdire une
expression organisé par des
manifestations et des rassemblements
pacifiques et c'est tout c'est
finalement à des expressions qui sont
complètement désordonnée et là ce n'est
pas possible je pense que monsieur
darmanin souffler sur les braises
je pense aussi qu'il veut empêcher qu
une expression en france contre la
politique de l'état d'israël
et ça c'est très grave on se demande
comment il peut arriver une décision
pareille alors en tout cas gérald
darmanin lui évoque clairement les
manifestations violentes hand de 2014 à
un pro palestinienne également notamment
barbès au cours desquels il ya eu des
incidents notamment un hôpital pris pour
cible
richard abitbol pour vous le ministre de
l'intérieur a pris la bonne décision ou
finalement il nous faudrait mieux
laisser les personnes s'exprimer pour ne
pas mettre de l'huile sur le feu encore
davantage
tout d'abord je tenais à dire que votre
reportage est déplorable et très
partisan ça serait un reportage sur des
faits on aurait montré la cité ça m'est
passé j'avais paula slayer juste avant
qui donnait le point de vue à tel aviv
et tous les soirs on a eu des tirs de
roquettes 1 je suis désolé mais j'ai vu
un reportage pratiquement
cinématographique monté par des gens qui
ont l'habitude de faire des montages
avait des soi disant mort etc
vous avez eu actuellement 87 morts
avec je me faisais pas interrompu
laissez-moi terminé s'il vous plaît vous
avez 87 morts aujourd'hui la plupart ce
sont des dealers du ramasse oui on en a
la liste d'ailleurs d'accord le si
c'était en syrie serait était dans un
combat comme ça quelques centaines voire
quelques milliers
deux morts d'autre part c'est pas du
tout un combat entre israël et les
palestiniens
c'est un combat entre un groupe
terroriste qui s'appellera mars condamné
comme tel comme terreur et ce non
seulement par les israéliens non
seulement par les états unis et l'union
soleil et de nombreux peine mais
également par les pays arabes eux mêmes
les pays arabes ont marqué le ramasse
comme groupement terroriste et monsieur
abbas d'après tout ce que j'ai pu voir à
l'air plutôt plutôt silencieux par
rapport à ce qui se passe parce que
n'oubliez pas quand même qui a tiré les
mici pas ce que vous appelez des
requêtes et pas des requêtes ce sont des
missiles
qu'est ce que ferait la france si on
avait mille missiles qui tombait sur
paris je vous pose une question que
ferait la france s'ils avaient mille
missiles qui tombait sur paris je vous
ferai remarquer qu'on a fini ce temps la
france par bavures entre guillemets à
bombarder un mariage en afghanistan 107
morts sans traitement s'il ya si peu de
morts avec tous les bombardements que
font les israéliens c'est parce qu'ils
prennent toutes les précautions pour ne
pas toucher les civils alors que le
ramasse fait exactement le contraire
il fait tout pour toucher des civils
vous n'avez pu également interrogé c'est
aux femmes qui a perdu son enfant
j'étais enceinte et qui a été blessé par
contre des juifs ne montre pas la
souffrance et nous montre pas no more
babylon pardonnez moi mais je tiens
vraiment à taizé se débattent dans la
mesure où on s'efforce très sincèrement
de montrer le donne quoi nous risquons d
soir les deux points de vue tous les
soirs et tous les soirs nous étions en
direct de tels avis pardonnez-moi
démontre sur le côté vous pouvez pas mon
truc on se connaît on a eu chaud là
répond on a eu notre reporter à tel aviv
juste à voir donc voilà ceci étant dit
je suis bonne mesurette bronner est
quelqu'un qui a incité à de
l'antisémitisme en 2014 ya eu quasiment
des programmes en france moi je suis
français
je me défends les français et comme
monsieur un repreneur va défendre les
palestiniens c'est son droit mais au
détriment des français parce qu'il a
poussée à des hordes antisémites en 2014
qui se sent faire un quasi programme à
la rue de la roquette
thion mais messieurs à leur mère c'est
le terreau d'un dîner samantha marolles
aussi à berne pour qu'il puisse répondre
puisque d'ailleurs roberto un bon gars
vous avez été arrêté placé en garde à
vue pour organisation d'une
manifestation interdite sur la voie
publique 1 alors que vous sortiez
justement d'un rendez vous au ministère
des affaires étrangères consacrée à ce
regain de tension au proche orient avant
de répondre évidemment à harry sarah
abitbol qu'est ce qu'on vous reprochez
précisément pour vous avoir arrêté
écoutez c'est hallucinant parce que donc
nous avons été tout à fait en discussion
tout à fait normal avec avec eux nos
interlocuteurs de la préfecture de
police qui nous ont signifié une
interdiction trois heures avant le
rassemblement ans est organisé comme on
a pu on a dit qu'on serait sur place ou
accueillir les personnes on a eu des
relations tout à fait normal avec et
officier de police sur place
on l'aura bien indiquer notre rendez
vous quai d'orsay nous ont d'ailleurs
escorté avec les trois députés trois
parlementaires qui étaient avec nous et
donc on a eu un entretien
bien sûr tout à fait qu à fait correcte
avec eux
le responsable de miss as des affaires
étrangères qui nous a reçus et on se
retrouve ensuite à la sortie je retrouve
en état d'arrestation
c'est juste hallucinant ça montre quand
même une dérive dans notre pays on a
l'impression qu'on veut faire taire les
voix qui doit le défendre les droits du
peuple palestinien et là je suis quand
même très inquiet je trouve que c'est
extrêmement grave ça laissait pas pour
rien qu'on se préoccupe de la question
du sort du peuple palestinien en france
c'est quand même nom pays
l'angleterre elle a raison pas dix ont
créé la situation qui se passe là bas on
a une responsabilité extrêmement
performant c'est quand même une aux pays
qui ont poussé aux accros d'oslo et qui
n'ont ensuite rien fait pour qu'il soit
impliqué israël s'est mis dans une
dynamique de
r de conquête territoriale et donc c'est
ça donc c'est cette dynamique de guerre
dont on voit les faits aujourd'hui il
faut se mettre quand même dans la dans
l'explication
un minimum historique toutes les chances
pour la paix ont été rejetées par israël
qui voulait absolument maintenir
continuer sa politique d'occupation de
colonisation de déni des droits des
palestiniens partout où ils sont
sexistes bonavent avant de s'étendre sur
le débat est d'élargir le débat
évidemment as confie je voudrais quand
même pour rester encore ce sont ces
manifestations françaises on a les
allures gerald débat tout à l'heure vous
faire juste écouter l'ancien premier
ministre socialiste manuel valls écouter
soutenir clairement israël et son droit
à se défendre et le gouvernement doit
veiller à interdire toutes ces
manifestations de soutien au hamas
prévues dans les jours prochains qui
seront une nouvelle fois des
rassemblements antisioniste et
antisémite à l'ats bertrand ils veulent
juste voilà rapidement parce que c'était
au tour de richard abitbol de vous
donner la contradiction mais c'est vrai
que ces rassemblements peuvent voilà
faire peur vous le savez en france qui a
parfois des voiles à des problèmes
notamment dans les banlieues on en parle
tous les jours ici on va pas se voiler
la face est ce que vous pouvez nous
garantir voilà que ce ne sont pas aussi
des rassemblements qui pourraient
devenir voilà violent nécessairement vu
le sujet explosif et vous le savez
évidemment
écoutez quand que vous me disiez
d'organisation et du collectif national
nous organisons des rassemblements dont
nous nous avons des mots d'ordre qui
sont parfaitement claires et donc nous
prenons les dispositions qu'il faut avec
les forces de l'ordre nous ne sommes pas
des mots non plus à nous substituer aux
forces de l'ordre pour qu'il n'y ait pas
d'incidents ce qui se passe à paris est
toujours très compliqué mais c'est
normal d'avoir le droit de manifester je
je me demande
malgré tout s'il ya eu aussi des des
menaces de la part de pro-israélien de
dire on va perturber leur portage alors
et qui font qu effectivement de mise
intérieur aille dans cette direction là
ça serait scandaleux parce que il à la
police républicaine
le ministère de l'intérieur
il est là pour protéger le droit de
manifester il est pas là pour
l'interdire et donc aujourd'hui se passe
quelque chose de très grave dans cette
partie du monde
on en est très sensible en france parce
que effectivement non porte une part de
responsabilité dans ce qui se passe là
bas et donc il est il y a il est donc
extrêmement important que l'on puisse
exprimer que l'on puisse dire aussi à
notre gouvernement
là il ne prend pas une position qui nous
convient aujourd'hui et donc c'est
quelque chose on doit pouvoir faire dans
un cadre d'un débat démocratique qui
doit être normal c'est normal de pouvoir
parler de ce site peut ensemble en
palestine c'est clairement clairement
vous craignez vous que ce conflit puisse
s'exporter notamment pendant dopé mais
notamment et en l'occurrence en france
clairement en tête parce que monsieur
bonnet se présente comme un soutien des
palestiniens
je considère que j'ai fait beaucoup plus
pour les palestiniens que monsieur al
bronner parce que j'aimerais bien qu'ils
se disent qu'est ce qu'il a fait pour
les palestiniens
moi je me suis battu pour qui est des
investissements en territoire
palestinien
moi je me suis battu pour me rapprocher
des pas dessiner je suis très ami avec
des palestiniens qui sont très proches
de ma superbe mahmoud abbas moi je me
suis battu pour qu'il ya un
rapprochement entre les musulmans et les
juifs en france
moi je me suis battu pour qu'il ya un
rapprochement avec les états arabes est
il ce raid qui a donné des résultats a
commencé récemment
si vous voulez aider des palestiniens
monsieur à leur honneur
je vous conseille de soutenir monsieur
mahmoud abbas est et non pas monsieur a
nié avec le ramasse qui est un groupe
terroriste
je vous soutiens j'ai votre soutien
devrait être sur le terrain pour
apporter de l'aide économique aux
palestiniens pas les inciter à la haine
pas les pousser vers la finale honnêtes
des juges non l'ensemble je voudrais pas
interrompu je m'excuse
souvenez vous de 2014 souvenez vous de
mai 2014 ont crié mort au juge d'accord
ont crié mort juste qu'est ce qui s'est
passé après jan
cacher attendez les styles a dit qu'est
ce qu'il a dit monsieur mohamed merah
quand il a tué les petits gérants à tout
le monde on te met pas les palestiniens
que vous lui avez mis dans la tête
kutaisi si vous êtes bien vous aider à
nantes ils ont peut-être d'aller au delà
des des règlements de compte personnels
pour prendre un peu plus personnel je ne
connais pas ce monsieur il personne ne
le connaît d'ailleurs sur stoke city
ces appels à la haine personne ne
connaît voilà c'est à il n'a jamais rien
fait pour les palestiniens ce monsieur
essayant pardonnez-moi richard abitbol
d'avoir un débat serein les morts en
france juste savane et mis lé team
battle elle était juge les maisons
chambre de aux airs à tora ce sont des
juifs les martyrs de l hyper cacher
c'était ici c'était pas les palestiniens
alors pas mal de réactions tout cas
politique
emmanuel macron ce soir d'ailleurs qui
s'est entretenu avec le président de
l'autorité palestinienne mahmoud abbas a
fermement je suis un condamné les tirs
revendiqués par le hamas et d'autres
groupes terroristes indique-t-il même
son de cloche du côté de marine le pen
je vous propose d'écouter la présidente
du rassemblement national
la pluie de missiles lancés par le hamas
sur les populations civiles israéliennes
est un acte inacceptable
espérons que les peuples israélien et
palestinien trouve la voie de la paix
bertrand est vraiment clairement vous
condamnez vous aussi aussi fermement les
tirs de roquettes lancés par leur hamas
sur israël
j'essaie surtout d'analyser comment on
en est arrivé là et on indique en
arriver là par une abnégation constante
les droits des palestiniens
on en est arrivé là à l'issue de
provocation de groupes haineux de
groupes extrémistes suprémacistes qui
ont crié mort aux arabes dans les rues
de jérusalem
on en est arrivé là par des
par une des religieux qui ont voulu des
religieux israéliens qui ont voulu
investir l'esplanade des mosquées dans
un esprit de conquête religieuse
on en est arrivé là parce que l'effectif
non le gouvernement israélien a permis
tout seul donc la question n'est pas
condamnée par les condamnez pas bertrand
et vendre comme le fait le président de
la république et le font beaucoup
effectivement de pays étrangers
le hamas étant considéré comme une
organisation terroriste sur la liste de
l'union européenne écoutez on était dans
une dynamique positive
il ya quelques semaines il aurait suffi
que israël permettre que les élections
aient lieu à jérusalem
on était dans une dynamique où
effectivement on arrivé à une nouvelle
unité du peuple palestinien à une
autorité vestiaires rénovés à une olp
rénové qui permet effectivement de
prendre des discussions au niveau
d'avoir des positions au niveau de
l'ensemble du peuple palestinien
je pense que tout ça c'est des occasions
qui ont été ratées avec une quand même
une forte responsabilité d'israël et
israël aussi à de ramasse avec ces
dernières provocations jérusalem a créé
deux les conditions qui ont qui nous
amène l'alizé c'est que si on veut une
dynamique de paix font c'est qu'ils vont
s'en donner les moyens
aujourd'hui on ne s'en donne pas les
moyens parce qu'on laisse israël vers
absolument ce qu'il veut et c'est ça qui
est le vrai premier à paraître
aujourd'hui dans la vie il ya sept
et c'est qui est grave aussi vous parler
d'importation en france un pont tout
simplement aussi que c'est quand un au
pays qui ont exporté le problème au
moyen-orient
mais revenons si vous parlez
d'importation au nom de quoi un conseil
représentatif des institutions juives en
france qui représente dont des français
juifs français français juif pas prendre
des positions demandant président de la
république de reconnaître que l'annexion
de jérusalem est la déplacement
l'ambassade des états unis de faire
pareil
va demander au ministère des affaires
étrangères de soutenir la colonisation
des territoires palestiniens au nom de
quoi
au nom de quoi ce même mouvement va
manifester quand il y à la conférence de
paris en janvier 2017 en disant que
c'est pire que l' affaire dreyfus
en fait c'est quoi ça c'est cette
conclusion aussi qui est extrêmement
dangereuse et je crois que une des clés
c'est que effectivement les français
juifs ne sont pas l'état d'israël mais
qu'il il faut vraiment que les
organisations qui crée cette confusion
elle s'arrête il faut qu'on ait un débat
en france qui soit un débat digne qui
soient effectivement n'est pas forcément
tous d'accord qu'il responsable tel ou
tel site est gratuit après t-il
on a une part envoyé comme le fait
manuel valls manuel valls il se
déconsidère il sait très bien qu'en que
la situation où elles et comment elle et
il connaît très bien la situation était
maire d'une ville jumelée avec un camp
de réfugiés palestiniens
donc il sait très bien il se déconsidère
totalement mais cet amalgame qui est
fait par manuel valls qui a été fait en
mars 2019 par emmanuel macron il est
mortifère le fait que par exemple
l'ambassade d'israël s'est donné la
parole à donner moi on arrive à la fin
du débat tisme que c'est un fait enfin
on y dans la confusion la plus de drames
et richard a vite balle vous êtes vous
êtes tous mais nous sommes d'accord et
qu'une partie voilà il faudrait un débat
peut-être apaisé y compris en france
pour ne pas créer la confusion ce qu'il
faut ce qu'il faut quand même rétablir
la vraie raison de ce conflit parce que
le monsieur ronald bronner avant que des
causes qui n'existe pas tout le monde
sait vous êtes journaliste vous savez
très bien que la véritable cause c'est
la suppression des élections
palestiniennes qui était dû au fait que
les sondages donnaient le ramasse
gagnants et que personne ne voulait que
le ramasse remplace autorité
palestinienne
c'est ça le coeur du du débat et le
coeur de la raison des terroristes
n'accepte pas et utilisent leurs moyens
de terroristes pour faire ce qu'ils ont
à faire c'est à dire toujours tuer des
juifs
essayez de taper
et de tendances et sur des civils leur
volonté c'est pas du tout de tuer des
militaires israéliens leur volonté c'est
de tuer des civils et le maximum de
civils comme le tout les terroristes
qu'est ce que fait un terroriste à paris
qu'est ce que fait un terroriste à
toulouse qu'est ce que fait un
terroriste à marseille ils tuent pour
terroriser et c'est exactement ça la
définition du ramasse et c'est pour ça
qu'il est considérée comme terroriste
par tous les pays digne dans ce pays
dans le monde
les etats unis l'union européenne les
pays arabes modérés
d'ailleurs vous avez dit vous avez
interdit la manifestation
le maroc a interdit les manifestations
comme en france parce qu'on sait très
bien que tant dans sa dérive
merci répond je suis en paye le prix ce
sont les juifs français
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
richard abitbol bertrand et brawn
d'avoir accepté ce ce face à face en
direct sur rt france merci à vous deux